what up space fam goals in here for
anime uproar and today I am going to be
talking about the latest exciting
developments in demon slayer if you like
demon slayer videos on this channel make
sure to smash that like button to let me
know if you haven't be sure to subscribe
and ring that notification bell so you
actually get notified when you demon
slayer videos drop for more demon slayer
content and crucial updates follow us on
twitter and instagram at anime out
drawer link in the description whenever
we get new information about the
upcoming movie and seasons we'll post it
there if you didn't know the upcoming
demon slayer movie is going to be
absolutely epic it's covering an amazing
arc and I'm psyched to see it there will
be manga spoilers in this video you've
been warned
we're going to be talking about the
latest chapter after all now without
further ado let's jump into it as you'll
remember in the last chapter chapter 175
upper moon ones head was caught off I
said that he might survive the
decapitation because Icaza was about to
and he's a lower-ranking demon moon but
I also said that I would be satisfied if
the fight was over because it literally
took everyone present to finally get his
head off
it was an epic display of teamwork and I
assume which heroes read late in cocoa
Siebels body and ganya's blood demon
arts might get in the way of him growing
his head back so it turns out the
mangaka will not let cocoa Cibo die
without an even more prolonged fight we
get some more memories of your Ichi and
I'm definitely not complaining about
that I love learning more about your
Ichi I think he's one of the most epic
characters and role models in the series
so I welcome as much information about
him as possible
anyways kakushi bow after getting
decapitated is remembering his brother
smiling he says that every time his
little brother smiled he couldn't help
but feel a sense of discomfort that
image of your Ichi smiling is the one
seared into Coco's evils heart whenever
Kaku she will brought up not having
successors to their breaths yo Deecee
would just smile he wasn't worried he
was always optimistic he had no concern
whatsoever if we remember from previous
chapters your ichi was so calm because
even though he was arguably the
strongest demon center in history he was
sure that children would be born who
surpass him not only did he not care
about being surpassed he even liked the
idea so much it made him smile every
time Co Khushi Bowl was the complete
opposite though he felt that his and his
brothers generation alone was
extraordinary and he took a lot of pride
in that fact because he had so much
pride he grown nauseous from the
irritation and discomfort that came with
the thought of not being the strongest
he hated the idea of being surpassed as
he hated the fact that his brother seems
to be effortlessly calm and happy all
the time while he seemed to be
frustrated and concerned all the time he
just couldn't understand what his
brother found so amusing then we jump
back to the epic fight we get the
amazing new Ichiro still holding on to
his blade even while he's all but dead
kuku she will contemplate the amazing
feats of these humans they don't let go
of their blades even when in pieces like
Mui cheeto they use blood demon arts
even as humans like Kenya they don't
bleed out even after getting cut down
time and again like simony they grow and
surpass their limits at a pace that
could challenge a demons like Yomi and
they do not practice the breath of the
Sun and yet their blades are dyed red
these are very interesting observations
that Coco Chabot is making in short he's
kind of saying that he became a demon
for no reason because he became a demon
to become stronger but these humans are
proving that they can do anything a
demon can do even while retaining their
humanity there are multiple paths to
becoming stronger and a demon way is the
cheap shortcut but you can get just as
strong if not stronger the right way by
working hard as a human you each he did
this and he was always stronger than his
demon brother it may require more hard
work but you don't have to give up your
principles and become a monster in order
to become strong then kakushi bow thanks
again about your Ichi
he thinks about why he was so amused
when he imagined a future where he'd be
surpassed
when kakushi bow would so much as think
about losing it would make his blood
boil
he decided after he almost got killed by
your Ichi that he would never lose again
even if his head were to be cut off but
then Coco she bows bleeding stops yo may
tell sodomy to not pull back his attacks
and to drive the demon moon into the
ground he says that Tokiko ain't gonna
give their lives
that they can't let that be in vain so
we are being told here that tokoto and
ganya are in fact dead and if anyone
would know it's kill me who has access
to the see-through world so at this
point it seems like their deaths are
pretty much confirmed from a writing
standpoint I don't think it's a bad move
but from an emotional standpoint I hate
that one of my favorite characters Mui
cheeto has to die at the age of 14 he
had so much frickin potential but as
Gomez said in the past all pillars have
to be prepared to sacrifice their lives
at any moment and Moo Ichiro died in the
manliest way possible he died protecting
what he believes in he died with his
principles intact
unlike Upper Moon whine and then there's
a case of ganya we get a look at the
back of san amis head you know that the
death of ganya impacts him a lot
although he acted harsh to his brother
he was only doing it because he loved
him and wanted to protect him no matter
what and now the person he wanted to
protect the most in the world appears to
be dead on the next page we get a full
half page of his face and he's crying
this has got to be one of the most
touching moments in demon slayer sana me
has been set up as a cold but hot-headed
jerk in the series he was mean to his
brother he was mean to Tangier oh and
worst of all he hurt our precious nesic
oh I still don't think I'll ever be able
to forgive him for that he was by far
presented as the cruelest of the pillars
in the beginning and that's why this
moment is all the more powerful this
seeming king of jerks this seeming
cold-hearted character is crying he's
dropping his tough-guy defenses and we
get to see just how much he cares about
his brother it's kind of like if Baku go
cried over my daughter before Baku ended
up dying we love seeing jerks get
emotional we love seeing the kind person
below the rough protective exterior and
that's why this is one of the most
emotional moments in the manga thus far
we are psychologically wired to be more
heavily impacted when a tough guy cries
then when a cry baby cries sorry Deku
and the mangaka uses that fact to really
make the most of this moment sodomy
screams let's do it Gras I'll shred him
to pieces
I'll keep hacking until there's nothing
left rah and quotes as you can see you
can't even put all of his feelings into
words his feelings are over
knowing so much that he has to use
unintelligible sounds to express his
anguish and anger both Kiyomi and Santa
me keep attacking ku ku Shi Bo notices
his body isn't crumbling and that he can
regenerate if he can get Kenya's tree
roots off of him he thinks he'll live
yet
ku ku she boasts someone else who has
access to the see through world confirms
that Muccino
and ganya are dead so he believes that
the effects of the sword and the blood
demon arts should fade soon he starts
conquering death by decapitation
Jiri grows his head and develops a new
form that is much more hideous than that
other form he previously called hideous
his old hideous form wasn't that
different from his normal form some of
you expected more of a transformation
than just a few porcupine like blades
sprouting from his body and I can't
blame you
well you guys now got quite a different
transformation this one truly deserves
the word hideous however it is
significant that koo koo she will viewed
the superficially different porcupine
samurai form as hideous I mean if he
viewed that form as hideous where he
pretty much looked the same
how will he view this completely
different monstrous form the thoughts he
had about his previous form were pretty
much foreshadowing his eventual reaction
to this truly hideous form the two
pillars keep pressing the attack while
kakushi Bo thinks that he has no attack
to fear now that he is able to
successfully regrow his head he thinks
that only the son can kill him now and
the son is not getting into this
dimension he believes he's finally
reached an unbeatable form and that
he'll never lose again that's when he
sees his hideous reflection in sauna me
sword if we've been paying attention we
know at this moment that he's going to
have a significant reaction to this
hideous reflection and he does he's
shocked by the hideous form it
represents what he has become internally
- he's become a monster that is willing
to sacrifice all codes and principles
for power then he gets a memory of his
little brother yo Deecee when he was
young
presumably this is before you Ricci
surpass Kakashi bow and skill Yuri Chi
at this point looked up to Kakashi Bo he
wanted to be like his older brother
while kuku she will want to be the
strongest samurai in the land yo Deecee
said that he would be the second
strongest samurai in the land
however after all these centuries it's
blatantly obvious at this point
that kakushi balls become someone or
something that his little brother would
never have looked up to the keyword in
your each E's words is samurai you see
samurai had a code of ethics called
Bushido Bushido includes traits like
honor loyalty politeness bravery and
benevolence at this point kikuchiyo
realizes he completely lost his way
while trying to become stronger he
abandoned the very attributes and
principles that make one a samurai
he abandoned practically all of them in
the pursuit of power he realizes this is
now what he wanted he didn't want to
become a monster then his body starts
crumbling where mu Ichiro stabbed him
with the red blade it seems like Muccino
finished what you're teaching a red
blade did penetrate him and it led to
his downfall well he's being attacked
and disappearing koku Shiba thinks one
last time that he should do something
but then he sees the image of his older
brother pitying him he says my deepest
sympathies brother and cries for him
then kikuchiyo says cut off my head
carve up my body smash it I cannot
swallow defeat and by that ugliness I
live in shame is this what I've lived
these centuries for what did I want to
not lose to the point I even became a
hideous monster to become stronger to
the point I even consumed humans to not
die to the point even devolved into this
wretched beast No then he says he just
wanted to be like his brother you're
Ichi then he passes on it seems that
kakushi bow is suggesting that he wanted
to live by the samurai code he wanted to
be brave but he was afraid and out of
the fear of the feet and death he chose
to become a demon he wanted to be loyal
and benevolent but in his search for
survival in power he killed humans he
wanted to accept his fate like the stoic
URI cheat but he kicked and screamed
against faith he was willing to do
anything to avoid the feet and death and
that turned him into a monster and he
ended up losing things even more
important than his life I've compared
you to Ichi to a stoic many times and
it's because he's so perfectly embodied
stoic philosophy and its principles for
one who follows stoic philosophy there
are more important things than life like
your principal
one stoic Kato killed himself by ripping
out his own guts so he wouldn't be
forced to compromise his principles
similarly you need she could have always
extended his life by becoming a demon
but he would rather die than compromise
his principles like that Google she will
lack this commitment to principles he
would have done anything no matter how
shameful or dishonorable to survive and
that is the difference between him and
yo Deecee
while you reach you was led by
principles Co Co Co was led by fear
ultimately his dying wish was that he
didn't give in to fear and that he had
the courage to live a more principled
life like your Ichi what an amazing
chapter it was tragic and we seemingly
lost some amazing characters but sanam
his tears and Coko she was in her
thoughts were extremely impactful
overall I really enjoyed this one and
can't wait to see where we go from here
let me know what you thought about this
chapter in the comments if you enjoyed
this video make sure to smash that like
one to let me know if you haven't be
sure to subscribe and ring that
notification bell so you actually get
notified when you demon slayer videos
come out leave suggestions for what
other demons their videos you would like
to see in the comments for even more
Demon Slayer greatness and crucial
updates about the new movie and the new
seasons you can follow us on Twitter and
Instagram at anime out drawer link in
the description a big thank you goes out
to our patrons over on patreon who help
make videos like this one possible I
especially want to thank our pro here or
to your patrons the one and only
Gilgamesh nothing but a fan Jason Wilson
Kings eldress angel Cruz Steelers poet
Pablo
atropos Wraith fitty dalla beat and
heretic GN and are the one tier patrons
the ones who stand atop all clans
Stephen and Radha a Lola not M Mattie
Mac 239 a makoto-kun if you enjoy our
work you can support more by going over
to patreon.com slash anime uproar and
becoming a patron today for as little as
$1 if you do so you'll get your name
featured in future videos alongside
these amazing people right here who
truly are pillars of the channel and
you'll even get access to our private
patron only discord so check out
patreon.com/lenguin
now at youtube channel and support more
content that way if you prefer you'll
still get all the same great benefits no
matter where you choose to support us
thanks again for everything I'm psyched
that we're past half a million
subscribers on the channel that is
absolutely mind-boggling and amazing and
until next time see you space cowboys
[Music]